are you struggling with your
relationship with God do you feel like
he's not listening to your prayers
well maybe it's because you're not fully
committed to him
and because you're not putting him first
in your life
in my new book bold pursued let me just
read a quote for you here I said God is
always waiting
the god of the universe is always there
waiting for us
God is more eager to reveal himself to
us than we are to seek him
it's time we turn back to God fully it's
time we've Fallen our knees and it's
time we return to the Bible
do you live your life according to the
Bible or do you want to change the Bible
to just fit in with your lifestyle
if you say you're a true Christian then
you need to live the way God wants you
to live and put him first in everything
I love you guys see in the next video
bye